hey guys Mary here and Blizzard actually
created a World of Warcraft cookbook
these are a bunch of dishes but they
made in real life to recreate dishes
that you can actually find in World of
Warcraft
in honor of Blizzcon we've decided to
make one I'm gonna go with this the
delicious chocolate cake I'm going with
this for a couple reasons it looks
really good also it's messy so I feel
like you guys won't notice if I make any
mistakes so I'm gonna show you guys
generally what we're working with so if
you want to make this at home you can we
didn't endorse any of these brands I
just didn't want to take them out of
their packages cuz I'm lazy so this is
flour and sugar milk butter heavy cream
then you got white chocolate chips food
coloring three eggs raspberries fresh
strawberries vanilla extract and then
baking soda baking powder and you'll
need like a pinch of salt as well we're
gonna switch the top down camera because
it's never done this before and I know
I'm gonna mess up first up we gotta make
the frosting cuz it's got a chill
measure out eight ounces of white
chocolate in a dish as well as a cup of
heavy whipping cream you're gonna heat
the cream over a stove until its
steaming but not simmering and you got
to pour it over the chocolate and stir
until it's all gooey you're not supposed
to add food coloring yet but I did it
anyway
cover and chill for four hours next up
you're getting four ounces of white
baking chocolate and then you melt it
you can put it in a container over hot
water to melt it quick while that's
cooling get a large bowl you're gonna
want the butter and the sugar combine
them then add your eggs and the vanilla
finally add in your dry ingredients
that's flour baking soda baking powder
and salt but don't do it all at once do
it little by little
remember that chocolate you melted
earlier well fold it into your batter
pour that batter into two eight inch
pans and you're gonna bake in an oven
set to 350 degrees for thirty minutes
set them out to cool next up let's work
on that frosting remember how I told you
to chill that frosting we'll take it out
use an electric mixer or mix it yourself
until it's fluffy or at least it looks
less shiny then take out another cup of
cream and start mixing it you can use a
mixer or hand mixer or whatever we got
to make whipped cream if you've never
done it before
wait until you have soft peaks forming
that's whipped cream so then you fold
the chocolate mixture you just whipped
into that cream and then beat it just a
little bit more but not too much you've
made frosting congratulations
divide the mixture into three bowls
you're putting about a quarter into one
bowl and then you split the rest into
two halves in that first bowl the one
with only a quarter of the frosting
you're gonna add fresh raspberries sugar
tablespoon of Port and a bit of
rosewater now if you don't have rose
water or you don't know what that is
just add more vanilla like I did mash it
until it's nice and pretty
that's your filling in one of your other
frosting bowls add more green nice
finally it's time to ice that cake baby
put your first base down and ice it with
the white icing all over then you put
your filling on top of that add another
cake on top of that and put white icing
all around then you put your green icing
on top oh yeah for some final touches
you just add fresh raspberries on top
that's a good-looking cake
thank you guys I made a cake this is the
delicious chocolate cake from the world
Warcraft cookbook it looks delicious
it tastes delicious tastes like
chocolate and cream and a butt ton of
sugar this is great
if you guys want to make this cake I'm
gonna list all the ingredients in the
description you guys can make this along
with me it's a pretty sweet treat for
not just our World of Warcraft fan but
for any cake fan so thank you guys so
much for watching the rad okay
you